Now that we've come up with this new equality. The absolute value of x minus 4
is greater than or equal to 4. How should we show that on a number line? I've
already selected three points for you where we may or may not need a kind of
parenthesis or bracket. Those points are negative 1, 4, and 9. And, of course,
those were all important when we were dealing with the absolute value of x minus
4 is less than or equal to 5. So, for each of these three points, please select
which symbol belongs on the number line at that point. You'll notice I've also
drawn four boxes down here for you. One for the area of the number line to the
left of negative 1. One for the area between negative 1 and 4. One for the area
between 4 and 9 and one for the area for the right of 9. I'd like you to check
off which of these areas of the number line should be shaded in.